welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition and this
episode we're breaking down the third
entry of lovecraft country
there's a lot to talk about and i just
want to get straight into it but
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here in regards to the show
and some elements of the book if you
enjoyed the video then please drop a
thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns like this every
day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into lovecraft
country
okay so the meaning behind the holy
ghost is something that
i really had to delve deep into to to
fully unearth something that i think
that the show is trying to convey
of course we all know that the holy
ghost derives from christianity
however it's also something that's
mentioned in the james baldwin essay the
price may be too high
baldwin is mentioned as the name of a
dog in the episode and hearing that kind
of sent me spiraling off in search of a
way
in which this and the episode were
linked now the price may be too high is
a 1969 piece
in which a protagonist goes in search of
something which would reveal the truth
about why society is the way that it is
towards black people
however in doing so they discover that
the system itself
doesn't want to change things at all and
other people in it do not necessarily
consciously decide this
it is rooted in their very dna in the
article baldwin puts across the point
that though he initially had been
writing for black
and white people he realized that the
latter and i quote
have been white too long and
consequently its effect on their
personality
their lives their grasp of reality has
been as devastating as the lava which so
memorably immobilized the citizens of
pompeii
they are unable to conceive that their
version of reality which they want me to
accept
is an insult to my history and a parody
of theirs
and an intolerable violation of myself
there's a lot going on there but it
basically states that we accept a view
of history
without being critical of it and enforce
it on others without accepting
any notion that it's false in england
the song rule britannia
has been getting a lot of debate
surrounding it recently with many
stating that it's part of british
history and something to be proud of
whilst others say that it brushes over
the true history of what was going on at
the time
baldwin said that he's tried to show
people but it's as frustrating as waving
a white flag in someone's face
and they turn around and tell you that
it's red again the title might not mean
this
but it's the only thing i could find
which had a connection to this episode
and i would be interested to see what
the creative teams say is actually going
on
and of course your opinions again i
don't want to be this white dude from
england who's like
here's here's what it's like being black
in america
and i am conscious that i probably come
across a bit like that
in the videos however i am trying to
educate myself and as always
your comments and information are
welcome as i'm trying to make these
videos as good as they can be
just yet please don't take me do these
breakdowns as me
trying to say that i know everything now
as for the episode itself
though connected to the prior 2 it does
go off in its own direction
i've been saying for the last two weeks
that the book does do this sort of thing
and it should be viewed more as an
anthology there's some big changes
coming down the line too
so expect to see a lot more wild
adventures involving the cast
that will likely work well as standalone
episodes
now we actually open at george's
homecoming service and though i
theorized last week that the
necronomicon
might be used to resurrect him i think
he's probably too far gone now
george was a massive part of the book
and he wasn't killed at the lodge
but the show is clearly changing things
up and it's gonna be interesting to see
how things happen going forward
now over the top of the scene we hear
narration by precious angel ramirez
who was part of the be true campaign by
nike it's very much about death
heaven and what we wish we could say to
those that have passed on
leti is the only one who is seated
during this and clearly the character
is suffering from survivor's guilt both
she and george were shot by samuel last
week
but he of course died while she was
brought back to life
guilt is something that we all feel at
some point i think it added a lot to her
character
knowing that she pretty much wanted a
fun road trip and now
has been left feeling like the fun that
she initially felt to send it into chaos
this is something that she pretty much
goes through with the house with it
initially seeming like
something that's gonna be an adventure
for her but it turns far more insidious
due to those that wish to control what
goes on in it we then cut to the title
card
which discusses how three people went
missing inside a house on the north side
of chicago
this is very much imbuing the episode
with a based on a true story type vibe
which is often used in horror i tried
searching for whether this was a true
event per se
and though i couldn't find any specific
instances of it
there are a lot of similar things that
happened during the time
ruby mentions a couple that were
attacked because they moved into an
all-white building and though she says
it only happened a year prior
it could be a reference to the cicero
race riot of 1951.
during this 4 000 white people attacked
an apartment building
that housed a black family in illinois
that could be the link but i do think
that the title card is just talking
about the events of the episode
as it does turn out to be true and also
it does put us in the air 1955
which is one on from the prior two
episodes now from here we jump to the
curtains being drawn
whilst an onlooker peers over letty and
her sister
throughout the series there have been
several watchful eyes over the character
whose intentions are often hidden away
and this very much embodies how the
neighborhood is
there's also a milk truck with the words
pure milk on the side
milk is often used to convey whiteness
and the pure part of the sentence
could be viewed as symbolism for how the
racist inhabitants of the area want to
keep it
we discover that letty has bought a 13
bedroom mansion
that just so happens to be haunted now
in the book we learned that when viewing
the property
she was told of its price and said that
it was too good to be true
with both her and ruby instantly
guessing that it was haunted
they still purchased it though whereas
here it seems like she was sold at
unfalse pretenses
early on it springs to life and almost
beheads letty with a guillotine-like
elevator
across town we jump to hippolyta and in
a room you can actually
see a telescope this is actually a cool
little nod to the book
as in that she used to gaze out into
space and try to discover planets
there's actually an ori later in the
entry which he becomes fascinated over
and i'm glad they're keeping things in
line with how she is in the source
material
now hippolyta actually nearly named
pluto and she sent a letter in to state
why it should be called that however at
the same time
a white woman in england sent in a
telegram of the exact same thing
and because of the speed of it it beat
hippolytus letter
and the woman was awarded the credit for
naming it now there is a lot of subtext
to that
and i do think that it's going to come
up later down the line it basically
states that white people have certain
advantages over black people even if we
don't consciously believe that we do
i think it's probably going to come up
in the season down the line and we'll
talk about that in more detail as we get
into the episode centered around here
now h takes out george's favorite book
dracula and begins to tear the pages out
of it
you don't really get the feeling that
she feels well anything
and there's just emptiness in her
actions she's trying to feel something
anything for george but it just doesn't
seem like she can
atticus and diana make breakfast and
tick talks about the new additions of
the guide
which is taken care of he's clearly
feeling guilty for what happened to
george
and trying to go above and beyond to
make things right but no matter what
he can't bring george back realising
he's worn out his welcome
tick goes to his father to find him
slumped over in the living room
with an empty bottle of liquor beside
him clearly he's also reeling from the
death of his brother
and maybe the knowledge that he might
not even be tick's father
i do think that he will actually be
revealed to still be his dad
and that this will help bring the pair
together once more but who knows
they may change things up for the show
there's also mention of a jackie
robinson type stranger
that in real life saved montrose and
george from a group of white men
and this of course inspired the dream
which tick had in the opening of the
first episode
we discovered that they've agreed to
tell h that it was sheriff hunt that
killed george
but clearly hippolyta knows that they're
lying across
town tick goes to letty looking for a
space to stay
and she's decided to move in on a sunday
as the neighborhood will be at church
this paranoia is soon proven right as
the neighborhood intimidate her and the
guests by strapping bricks to their car
horns
the police even drive by at one point
and show which side they're on
by letting it continue now we mentioned
in our first episode breakdown that
typically in horror movies when the cops
show up
there's a feeling of relief however in
lovecraft country it's the complete
opposite
and knowing that the police are the
biggest monsters means that the house
have
absolutely no one to turn to for help
the people in the area put signs up
saying that they're a white community
and that undesirables must go they avoid
using the word black
and put undesirable instead but the
subtext is obvious
i feel like this is covering their own
backs as they can say they weren't
racist
and we're rather just getting bad people
out of the neighborhood but yeah
it's it's pretty obvious now on top of
this we discover that the house is
indeed haunted
and oh my god what the hell is that
now what makes this episode so
terrifying is that we don't know whether
it's the ghost
or the neighbors which are the ones
causing the issues in the house
and we see that the boiler is almost
overloading this is a reference to the
shining
and in the book the boiler actually
exploded at the end of it
and burned down the overlook hotel we
also see letty step over a bear trap in
the basement
and these were actually used in real
life to catch runaway slaves
it's an absolutely horrendous way to get
someone and even though it was closed
watching leti tiptoeing around it it
still made me seize up a bit
in the basement she hears banging and
then discovers a hidden room with
atticus
this becomes a big location later in the
episode
and it could also be linked to the
portal episode that i have no doubt is
coming down the line
we then jump to the house warming night
and can hear the horns still blaring
outside
ruby gets a band to play to drown them
out but whenever we cut to the outside
they can be heard being used as an
intimidation tactic
the party still continues and you very
much get the idea that the noise
like the neighbours are something that
letty and co are just trying to live
with
even though they shouldn't have to
they've done absolutely nothing wrong
but they just can't be left alone and
the noise like racism
is something that always exists around
them it's rarely on the surface
but it's constantly clawing away at them
and all they can try and do is distract
themselves
whilst it goes on we as viewers hope
that one day the noise stops
but this episode puts across the idea
that ignoring it
probably isn't the best tactic however
that doesn't mean that the black people
should be the ones that have to stop the
noise
and i think that the subtext of this
entry conveys that it should be the
white people that do it
the noise is clearly ruining the
neighborhood for them just as much as it
is for those in the house
and when you think about it their
actions are just as damaging for their
own community
as it is letties but hey try explain
that to them
we all live on the same planet and it
would be great if everyone could get
along
but it's just people who want the noise
to continue
now at the party there's also a mention
of martin luther king jr
and how he was initially planning on
marrying a white woman
there's mention of him being forced to
marry a black woman instead
and let you sort of place this up and
makes a comment about it i actually
looked into this book couldn't find that
much
i don't really want to interpret it in
the wrong way so make sure you leave
your comments below
on what this could actually mean in the
basement diana plays with ouija board
and the spirit behind it says that
they're george as this wasn't in the
book
i'm not sure what's going on here but
it's a very scary scene
cut to the party and ruby plays is you
or is you ain't my baby
this plays into the scene itself and the
bouncer tree from the first episode asks
tick about letty
as he wants to make a move but tick
makes it clear that he likes her
however she's dancing with someone else
but the attraction is clearly there
between them
she goes to the bathroom and then we see
a creepy as hell ghost
looking in on her in this episode we
actually discover what happened to them
and it turns out that they were
experimented on by the home owner
this motif actually pops up more and
more in the book as we get into it
and i don't want to spoil things just
yet but yeah this is sort of the first
step
lettie and tick get it on and take
notices blood paletti says it's her time
of the month
we do however learn that this was
actually her first time thus
tree was lying about them in high school
we then see that there's a burning cross
on the lawn
and this is a terror tactic used by the
clan which actually comes from medieval
europe
originally scottish warriors would set
fire to establishments as a sign of
defiance or a call to battle
the clan then adopted this and the fact
that the cross is part of religious
iconography
further adds to how terrifying this is
added kissing others at the party arm up
while celebi storms out with a baseball
bat and smashes up the cars
enough is enough and sometimes you have
to fight back and she destroys the
bricks
showing that they won't be scared
anymore the police arrive and they get
down on their knees
and even though they were the ones
trying to dissolve the situation
they're arrested whilst the burning
cross gets completely overlooked by the
officers
in the back of the van the policeman
goes on a racial tirade
and denies ever receiving any of the
complaints they filed
this further showcases how the police
overlook things when it comes to black
people
similar to the cross he tells her about
the bodies that were found in the house
itself
and we hear the name winthrop this is
actually horatio winthrop
who is teased in the second episode and
this ties into the order of ancient
dawn cut today 9 and letty has clearly
been beaten up by the police
due to the bruises on her face in the
basement which she's turned into a dark
room
she finds scratches all over the
photographs upon placing these together
a ghostly face is formed that tells her
to get out
this is of course a staple of haunted
house movies and we see that
a lot of the tenants are moving out lety
let's slip that her mother gave her
and only her an inheritance which he
used to buy the property
with ruby is of course furious as letty
was estranged from her
but we learned throughout the episode
that it was actually christina behind it
to me this showcases that those in power
would rather have those down the ladder
fight amongst themselves
rather than focusing their attention on
what's really going on
this was definitely a motif in the
second episode and i'm glad that it's
being brought across here
letty starts to research the house and
here she discovers not only the
connection to winthrop
but also dr hiram epstein an
astrophysicist that experimented on
people
namely the ghosts that we see in the
house in the book we learned that
epstein actually managed to create
portals
which stretched across the solar system
and he dumped people on the other side
of these
i don't want to spoil the story too much
but you never know a character might end
up going through one of these portals
and ending up on a planet across the
universe now epstein himself
i believe is actually a nod to james
marion sims
sims is labelled as the father of modern
genealogy
and though often praised in my opinion
he was an
absolutely disgusting man sims actually
carried out surgeries on black women
without the ease of anesthetic
in order to gain a better understanding
of the human body i think this is
completely inexcusable
and the guy was an evil evil man and
rightly so his statue was taken down in
2018.
now as for the show letty admits the
atticus that it was the first time and
she states that she needed to actually
feel something
and that she's been trying to avoid
everything that's going on but must
finally face up to it
much like the night in which she smashed
up the cars letty says she won't hide
anymore
and at the house she holds an exorcism
that will really
get you goat terrible jokes continue now
in the basement they join hands
whilst the neighbors descend on the
property with bats the ghosts tear them
apart
including a giant with a baby's head the
elevator decapitates someone
and seeing these guys get their just
desserts is a brilliant part of the
entry
the exorcism initially seems to work but
when the sprinklers set off
we know that it's failed this wipes off
the seal of protection on their
foreheads
and thus the trio become vulnerable the
woman who is carrying it out becomes
possessed by the spirit of hyrum
who then tries to kill atticus before
taking him over
the spirits of those that he killed come
forward and banding together with leti
they managed to banish him in the
process their spirits are healed
whilst his decays eventually he and the
ghost disappear
and hats off to smell a bell for
absolutely nailing the emotion in this
entry
we close the episode with letty getting
interviewed for a newspaper
and we learned that she's turned the
house into a sanctuary for the black
community
we follow the elevator as it descends
into the basement and watch glyphs light
up before seeing the three bodies laid
out alongside the other eight that died
the episode ends with christina's silver
car pulling up and atticus goes to see
her at the location that letty mentioned
earlier in the episode
it's here that we learned that christina
was the one that gave letty the money
and she was also the person that
influenced her into buying the winthrop
house
winthrop stole pages from the book of
names and though we start to learn about
him
before we can discover more tick pulls a
gun on christina who uses her powers to
stop this from going any further
christina similar to caleb in the book
is a very complex character
and she states that her father was
invulnerable but during the ceremony
last week he wasn't
and she knew that tick had an
opportunity to kill him christina wants
the pages bound
and who knows where things could be
going forward
well i i do because i've read the book
but let's just say it gets very
interesting
and christina uses the fact that she's a
white woman to her advantage
knowing that atticus will pretty much
face all kinds of persecution
but even attempting the act it closes
out the episode
and leaves a lot of things up in the air
namely ruby
and letty's relationship and what
christina's plans are
now as for the next episode it does look
like christina and william are gonna go
to the group
in order to try and strike up a deal
they really want the pages of the book
i think it will be them that tells h
what happened to her husband before they
descend into an indiana jones type entry
that will have them going into the
deaths of the earth to discover where
the pages are
it does look like the group are actually
going through the basement into the
depths of the earth
in order to try and find the pages but
hey we're gonna see what happens now
there are a lot of theories that
christina and william
are one in the same and that the
character's desire to become a man
has manifested as this person they're
never on screen together
and with caleb not being present i can
see this being a possibility
either way there's a lot to look forward
to and hopefully you enjoyed the
breakdown
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you missed our other breakdowns then
i'll leave them linked at the end
and definitely check them out if you
want something else to watch if you want
to support the channel and get see
content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat to
us on the discord server linked in the
description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next week
take care peace
you